let's talk about all the gorgeous places
in our favorite movies that you can
actually spend the night at I'm talking
about the Iron Man Villa with panoramic
Beach views the Dutton Ranch that
actually functions as a working farm and
the infamous Twilight house let's talk
about the insane mansion that supposedly
set on a Seaside cliff in Malibu owned
by everyone's favorite superhero Tony
Stark the question is is it real well
yes and no there's definitely not a
futuristic mansion on that Cliffside in
Malibu nothing would actually even be
legal to build in that spot but there is
an Iron Man Villa in Cape Town South
Africa that you can 100 percent stay at
today that is if you have a spare 300
000 lying around yeah 300
000 dollars per night the home is
influenced by 1960s California
architecture and and has some incredible
panoramic views of Clifton's beaches the
12 apostles mountain range and the
Atlantic Ocean right below so yeah
absolutely gorgeous almost definitely be
staying there strictly in my dreams so
are there any Yellowstone fans here
anyone who's actually watched the show
has definitely pondered staying on their
Montana Wilderness set some good news
you actually can the real Dutton Ranch
is in Darby Montana and it has cabins
you can rent by the night the most
surreal thing in the world and the most
humbling thing in the world is when
you're sitting in your own living room
you can sit in my living room or you can
leave it watching a show that's filmed
in your house the land actually still
functions as a working farm but the
current owners have offered up two
cabins as vacation rentals Lee dutton's
cabin and Rip's cabin there are 360
degree views of the Bitterroot and
Sapphire mountains the cabins were built
in 1916 and serve as staff housing in
total they can sleep up to eight guests
and start at 1200 per night I'm talking
specifically about the Lord of the Rings
and Hobbit trilogy's homes if you're a
fan of The Lord of the Rings series just
take a little trip to New Zealand where
the majority of Middle Earth was filmed
you can take a guided trip through the
Shire have a two-course banquet Feast
served inside the green dragon Inn which
includes a hobbit South fairing beverage
and then take what they call a second
breakfast tour you can also experience
real Middle Earth and get an in-depth
tour of the full 12-acre set past The
Hobbit holes and the mill just take a
quick trip to Dubai to experience the
Armani Hotel enclosed inside the tallest
building in the world that Tom Cruise
climbed up in Mission Impossible if you
haven't seen the movie definitely watch
it even if just for this scene alone
rates start at 520 a night which
according to the reviews include some
Stellar customer service the mirrored
walls are also an incredible aesthetic
and the entire entire building just like
loses luxury fun fact this building can
fit 2.7 Eiffel Towers inside its walls
if you're a fan of the Harry Potter
series you know that there are tons of
places from the movie that you can visit
but you can actually stay at the school
that inspired Hogwarts and also served
as its Great Hall location I'm talking
about Christ Church College in Oxford
England with rates starting at 75 a
night obviously it serves as a college
most of the time so the rooms are only
available to book when students aren't
staying there typically during summer
and Easter break but otherwise you can
definitely fulfill your Hogwarts dream
and wander those dark rustic corridors
as you play the Harry Potter theme from
your phone this one is for all of my
horror movie fans out here let's talk
about the inspiration behind The Shining
Wendy I'm home so Stephen King and his
wife ended up at the Stanley Hotel in
Colorado just as it was about to go out
of business it was once absolutely
stunning but at the time it needed a bit
of a makeover resulting in a bit of a
restless night even though the place was
eerily quiet Stephen King ended up
having a nightmare which was the
inspiration behind the classic novel
after waking up in a cold sweat he went
out to the balcony and had a cigarette
and ended up coming up with a plot now
the hotel is a major success and guests
can wander through the renovated 142
room hotel and even stay in one of the
spirited rooms which are rumored to have
high levels of Paranormal Activity
obviously I'm talking about Monica's
incredible New York City Apartment in
friends still wondering how they were
able to afford such a place but such is
TV magic I guess so it's called the
friends experience that's a product of
collaboration between Superfly and
booking.com basically you can spend the
night in Monica's New York City
Apartment for literally less than 20
dollars which is significantly less than
the rent in my actual apartment I'm
trying to move in if you're located in
New York City Brussels Seattle
Philadelphia or Birmingham you can take
advantage of the friends experience and
enjoy recreated props costumes and
exclusive merch and if you're not in any
of those locations like myself you can
still order some exclusive friends merch
from their online store anyone trying to
spend the night in the room where Edward
was watching Bella sleep I like watching
you sleep well you gotta get in there a
year ahead of time because this house is
fully booked until then what's cool
about it is that it is truly an actual
Charlie and Bella Swan House that was
used for filming so yeah you can
actually sleep in Bella's bedroom or
hang out in the lookout room that
overlooks the front yard if your Team
Jacob you can also stay in what they
call the Jacob Black guest room just off
the main downstairs entryway it's a
two-night stay minimum but you might be
able to stay for 1 bookend night
starting at 380 per night so when Tony
Stark wasn't hanging out in his Malibu
mansion He took some Solas in a quiet
little Lakeside Cabin you can do the
same with an Airbnb reservation in
Fairburn Georgia it'll run you a
thousand bucks a night but it'll sleep
six and you'll have 2 000 acres of land
to explore during your stay it's pretty
secluded located on a private property
in the middle of buchart farm but it's
conveniently only 30 minutes away from
Atlanta this could be your next very
expensive home away from home to do a
little fishing watch a horse show and
pretend to be Tony Stark I'm talking
Infamous shirtless Daniel Craig as 007
The One and Only Ocean Club resort is
the tropical setting in the movie where
he puts the Sea View Villa on M's Tab
and the hotel library is where all of
those poker games take place they have
multiple locations all over the world
and each one seems to be more stunning
than the last it will run you a pretty
penny though upward words of 1500 a
night lost in New York or rather Lost In
The Plaza Hotel I don't know I don't
know how Kevin managed to swing that but
I think I'd rather spend time alone in
the plaza versus whatever trip my family
found on Groupon there's this phrase
people say nothing unimportant ever
happens at the plaza which I can
definitely believe to be true we all do
it first opened in 1907 and there were
already tons of reports buzzing around
about how great it is I mean who can
blame them it is located at Central Park
and Fifth Avenue which if you know
anything about New York is one of the
most desired locations just to even walk
around so yeah needless to say I was a
bit jealous of Home Alone Kevin's
Escapade to a hotel that I'll probably
never see the inside of here we have yet
another stunning Hotel this one is in
Salzburg Austria the film's viewers know
the place as the Von Trapp family home
and the hotel definitely leans into it
from the Lakeside Terrace to the
Venetian room which was created on a
studio Sound Stage the hotel is filled
with references to the fun trap Family
the 55-room hotel was built in 1736 and
is surrounded by 17 acres of land and
has incredible views of the surrounding
mountains so who's saving up for the
next weekend trip I know I'm trying to
hit up that Yellowstone Ranch but I
don't know if I can wait an entire year
to get into my Bella Swan era which spot
are you putting on your vacation list